maxine waters big mouth may have gotten
derrick chauvin off the hook in the
trial regarding the death of george
floyd
my phone gives me alerts on things that
just happened
i mean you can't avoid it and it is so
pervasive that it is i just don't know
how this jury
it can really be said to be that they
are free from the taint of this
um and now that we have us
representatives uh
threatening acts of of
violence in relation to the specific
case
it's it's mind-boggling to me well i'll
give you the congresswoman waters may
have given you
something on appeal that may result in
this whole trial being overturned but
what's the state's position
as well it should as well it should we
we played what
maxine waters said yesterday was very
clear it was a call to riot
and the so this new information that
could
affect the trial of of derek chovin for
the death of george floyd
the new information isn't about anything
that happened on the day and the drugs
in the neck and the
police officers no it's going to be a
political consideration
because you have elected democrats in
this country
who are calling for riots trying to
interfere in our justice system
maxine waters is a greater threat to
justice
and peace in this country than the worst
possible
imaginable cop ever this is the george
floyd trial week
when the whole nation for some reason is
focused on this one
criminal trial where a cop
used force on a guy with a long rap
sheet who was high on drugs and
resisting arrest
and there's a question did he use too
much force did he not use too much force
did he murder this guy did he commit
manslaughter
all in the weeds of what is essentially
a local a local crime story
that the left has turned into a
national reckoning on race and they've
contrived all sorts of aspects of it
and they have now explicitly threatened
to riot and burn down the country
as they did last year if they don't get
the
outcome that they want in this trial
it's hard to see
how the jury does not convict here
it's hard to see not because of the
evidence i think the prosecution's done
a pretty weak job
and i think the defense has done a
pretty good job and i think so many
facts of this case were completely
hidden or
distorted in the political melee that
took place in 2020.
however think about what's going to
happen if this jury doesn't convict
their their lives are going to be ruined
they're going to be targeted by
a murderous mob that has the explicit
support of elected officials
and many other people in the media their
families are going to be targeted
you're already seeing this sort of thing
happen there was a paramedic who donated
a little bit of money
to the defense of of kyle
what's his name kyle rittenhouse in
kenosha wisconsin
people are showing up to this guy's
house now this is just what happens when
you contradict
the left's narrative on this so just for
self-preservation i suspect
that the jury here is going to convict
the judge
actually makes this point himself this
goes back to what i've been saying from
the beginning
i wish elected officials would stop
talking about this case
especially in a manner that is
disrespectful to the rule of law
and to the judicial branch in our
function
i think if they want to give their
opinions they should do so in a
respectful
and in a manner that is consistent with
their oath to the constitution
to respect the co-equal branch of
government
their failure to do so i think is
abhorrent but i don't think it is
prejudices
with additional material that would
prejudice history they have been told
not to watch the news
i trust they are following those
instructions and that there is not
in any way uh a prejudice to the event
beyond the articles that we're talking
specifically about the facts of this
case
a congresswoman's opinion really doesn't
matter a whole lot anyway
so motion for miss trial is denied okay
so he
denies the motion here for mistrial but
he says look on appeal
if let's say chauvin is convicted if
it's all thrown out on appeal
there really might be a strong case to
be made here but but in this trial
i trust that the jury is not watching
the news so look if the jury
is not watching the news at all they're
really they're not talking to anybody
about this trial
and they have i don't know general
amnesia
from 2020 then perhaps
then perhaps chauvin gets off
or he gets some lesser conviction but if
it's
if they're in any way talking to anybody
if they're
listening to the news if they can even
hear the screams and whales and threats
that are floating through the air
especially in minnesota right now then
it's very very
difficult to see how he gets off
blm already burned the country down it's
not as though this is some new news
story
everyone knows about it but i think
frankly by the way
le the left-wing establishment is
probably hoping
that chauvin does get off because if if
chauvin is convicted then that's the end
of the story
that's the end of it for the media they
won't get their ratings that's the end
of it for the radicals they won't have
an excuse
to riot in the street and and extort
more concessions out of the
establishment
now mowing the flat catchers to use the
phrase of tom wolf the writer
uh that will be the uh
end of it for the liberal establishment
itself which is constantly trying
to take more power so
what are they going to do i don't know
they're probably going to encourage the
riots maxine waters
has gone viral because of that clip that
that was going around yesterday where
she said we need to get more
aggressive we need to get more
confrontational more confrontational
than burning down multiple cities
what's more confrontational than that a
nuclear weapon but this is not
new for maxine waters maxine waters has
been doing this
for decades maxine waters did this
during the rodney king riots back in the
early 90s
as i stand here nine people are dead
my last count last this morning before i
tried to get some sleep
was over 50 something fires raging all
over los
angeles the fire started in my district
and one of the largest was right around
the corner from my house
there are scores of injuries and still
anger and frustration and people who
plan on staying on the streets and
expressing their outrage and anger in
any way they deem necessary
there are those who would like for me
and others and all of us
to tell people to go inside to be
peaceful
that they have to accept the verdict i
accept the responsibility of asking
people not to
endanger their lives i am not asking
people not to be angry
i am angry and i have a right to that
anger and the people out there have a
right to that anger
maxine waters does not have a right to
any anger she
she does not maxine waters does not
what maxine waters is doing is
provoking riots and what she says here
is look i'll
i accept the responsibility of telling
people not to go out and endanger
their own lives that can be read in one
of two ways either the writers who are
saying don't go out there and
commit these crimes and put yourself in
a dangerous situation
or that could be just the law-abiding
citizens and the shop owners saying hey
look i'm telling you don't go out don't
fight back don't endanger your own life
either way
not a great concession for this i'm
going to accept that
but i'm not going to tell people not to
be angry i'm not going to tell people
not to express that anger
you should if you cared about your
country you would you would do that if
you cared about justice
you would do that now she's even lost
the facade of trying to be reasonable
now she just says you get up on their
face and you mob them and you get
conf more confrontational after burning
down the country for a year
so she she no longer has that filter
this happens
to most people as they get a little bit
older
all of that to say i see the leftist
strategy
the leftist strategy is you
encourage the riot you encourage the
chaos and then as a result you get the
crackdown
and they like both of those things they
like the chaos because they can extort
concessions
on the left and then they like the
crackdown because that gives them
more power i just never want to hear
about a right-wing insurrection again i
never want to hear about it i don't want
to hear about
january 6th and capitol hill
and the greatest worst insurrection in
u.s history i don't want to hear about
it
as long as maxine waters faces zero
consequences which is exactly what's
going to happen
then i just don't want to hear about it
i don't there's these things are not
comparable
what blm and antifa did to the country
in 2020 what they're probably going to
do in a week or two
just not comparable to the guy with the
crazy horns jumping on the
on the table in the capitol building
stop
wait wait okay i'm glad i've got your
attention
i need you to like and subscribe you got
to smash the button do whatever
crazy verb you got to do you got to do
it because
youtube sometimes doesn't love us
okay and they don't necessarily want to
pump our videos up to the top of your
feed so if you don't want to miss a
video
make sure you like and subscribe right
[Music]
now
you